so you're a man in somalia with a wife
and three kids it's 1991 and the somali
navy was just disbanded this is
important because the fish that live off
the coast of east africa are super
valuable they're located near a
migration route for some of the biggest
tuna in the world and for generations
the people of somalia relied on fishing
for food and money now that the navy was
disbanded there was a huge power vacuum
there was no more somali military to
protect your waters from foreign
fishermen after lifetimes of depending
on the ocean for fishing now anyone
could come and take your source of food
and wealth
so you're living in extreme poverty
you've got a family to feed and now
everyone else is taking your fish and
your government is not there to defend
you
you are on your own so what do you do
well you take the violence into your own
hands
the civil war in somalia meant that
there were always weapons around and
everyone knew how to use them so at
first these men started out as kind of
like a neighborhood watch but from the
ocean to stop foreign vessels from
taking their fish you even called
yourself savers of the sea but not after
long you realize that hey i have the
ships i have the guns these intruders
aren't playing fair so why should we
associate
so what started out as a coast guard
service turned into a kidnapping and
ransom operation i'm the company
sure fishing can make money but boarding
a ship kidnapping the crew and demanding
a huge ransom was much more profitable
and as a newfound pirates you were
making more money than you could ever
dream of
suddenly you go from being a fisherman
living in poverty struggling to feed
your kids to making hundreds of
thousands of us dollars and all you have
to do is kidnap a few people hold them
hostage and torture them for a few years
and then boom you become a millionaire
in a country where the us dollar goes
very far
there was no turning back piracy was the
only way to go
today piracy is organized strategic
full-blown criminal operations that use
violence kidnapping and theft as their
entire business strategy their young men
armed with ak-47s machine guns and even
night vision goggles and they have
plenty of targets to work with with over
20 000 ships passing by somalia every
year and this is how you can be a pirate
yourself
fortunately you don't need to be a
pirate to make money these days one of
the most common ways people are getting
rich today is with e-commerce selling
physical products online through a
platform like shopify i personally have
a lot of friends that have become really
successful just from e-commerce and when
you start out it's okay to use the
built-in native shopify shipping
integration to actually ship out your
orders but the problem is once you start
getting more orders in like 30 to 50
orders a day that built-in shipping
integration just doesn't cut it anymore
you need something more robust to handle
that kind of volume so you can continue
to make more money that is where
shipstation comes in shipstation is the
fastest easiest way to get products to
your customers there's a reason why over
a hundred thousand ecommerce merchants
use shipstation no other shipping
software makes order fulfillment quicker
easier and more affordable shipstation's
easy to use interface combines order
processing inventory management and
customer communication all in one place
it makes your life easier by keeping
track of orders from any sales funnel
finding the best shipping carriers and
extremely discounted rates automating
basically every shipping test with just
a few clicks you can even manage orders
right from your phone and it's available
in the uk australia and canada
shipstation is so good that 98 of
companies that you ship station for a
year keep using it as long as they're in
business it is that good ship more in
less time with shipstation just go to
shipstation.com to get a 60 day free
trial that's two months free of no
hassle stress free shipping visit
shipstation.com
ship station make ship happen thanks to
ship station for sponsoring this video
[Music]
in 2012 an american journalist named
michael scott moore was in somalia
conducting research for a book on modern
day pirates but he got a little bit more
than he bargained for when michael was
on his way back from dropping off his
partner at the airports there was a
truck waiting for him at his hotel at
first he thought there were bodyguards
here to protect him but it was actually
12 gunmen that immediately came over to
the side of his car they shot into the
sky open the door and pulled michael out
the pirates proceeded to beat michael
break his glasses and force him into
another vehicle before driving deep into
the bush that was the beginning of
michael moore's life as a hostage to
somali pirates he would be held captive
for 977 days yep more than two and a
half years he was held on both land and
sea during his imprisonments he even
tried escaping once by jumping over the
side of a tunable at nights during his
time being held hostage by somali
pirates he watched other catholics being
tortured the pirates hung hostages
upside down from a tree and beat them
with bamboo canes and after two and a
half grueling years michael scott moore
was finally released in 2014 the price
for his freedom a ransom of 1.6 million
dollars an amount that was negotiated
down from 20 million to 1.6 million by
moore's mother and the worst part is
that michael scott moore wasn't an
outlier pirates kidnapped people out of
the ocean all the time in 2020 alone 135
crew members were kidnapped by pirates
[Music]
to hijack a ship somali pirates approach
it from the back on the speed boats then
they threaten to shoot the ship with
rpgs and rifles if they aren't let on
board once they climb onto the ship they
seize control and then it's game over
for the crew
look at me sure i'm the captain now the
crew is detained the ship is secured and
now it's time to negotiate a hefty
ransom somali pirates are willing to
hold prisoners hostage for years at a
time if that's what it takes and in
terrible conditions mind you this man
was tied to a tree where he has spent
the last two years
we were kept
under a tree that is our shelter it's
wilderness plain land which is sandy so
on this too much air when there's too
much wind the sun blow at night
you you have to expect snakes and
scorpions and spiders giant spiders
and and
the people don't care
like paul and rachel chandler a british
couple who was sailing in their yachts
when all of a sudden they were shot at
by somali pirates and kidnapped in the
middle of the nights they were held
hostage for over a year 388 days during
that time they were kept in solitary
confinement and whipped the channels
were finally released when the friends
and family paid the pirates a few
hundred thousand dollars and although
ruthlessly simple these memphis have
worked time and time again
how much do you think you could get if
you would kidnap me from you at least 50
50 million naira
in 2005 somali pirates were getting
around 350 000 for every ship they
captured just six years later they were
being paid six million dollars to
release a single greek owned ship that
is a huge increase in profits over such
a short period of time in 2010 it was
believed these pyrex made 238 million
dollars from kidnappings and ransoms by
now somali pirates held a monopoly on
piracy throughout the world accounting
for 92 of all pirate attacks in the same
year
last year how many attacks did you do
of course last year of course i struck
knowledge
none less than
15 attacks because we were not pleased
at its peak somali piracy was costing
the global economy 18 billion dollars
per year that's over three times
somalia's gdp and you can even invest in
somali pirates pirate ships and weapons
don't come cheap for inspiring pirates
so somalis with a lot of money will
often fund the pirate ships and weapons
to receive a percentage of the bounty
but over in nigeria their pirate
business model was completely different
[Music]
piracy all depends on where you're
located what's available and what your
pain point is take nigeria for example 2
million barrels of oil are produced in
nigeria every single day as of 2019
they're the ninth largest exporter of
oil in the world but none of those
billions of dollars goes to the nigerian
people no it's going to huge companies
exploiting their oil reserves like chill
if you look at the ground here you see
all this thing is the group oil
look at it see it enter into the ground
soak it through look us all over while
companies like shell and chevron have
built an empire 70 of the people in
their drilling zones were living on less
than one dollar per day despite this the
oil companies refused to hire any local
people you come to explore it here and
you don't want employee that is why that
is the major reason why we are doing
this you don't want to employ us and
you're exploiting from us their homeland
was being destroyed by drilling their
livestock died and they're struggling to
survive
if you're a desperate nigerian male
turning to piracy and stealing oil from
cargo ships is a no-brainer we have
seeking of this this trouble is not
about me it's all about the nigerian
people if this continues
what do you expect from my son
what do you target my target is flow
stations
pipelines
the jackets
and pc
[Music]
they are
my targets
so piracy became a full-blown criminal
enterprise in the gulf of guinea off the
coast of nigeria and their business
tactics were very violent for a while
anyone who had anything to do with the
oil companies was in danger around this
area in 2012 there were nearly a
thousand attacks on ships by west
african pirates their methods often
involve things like kidnapping torture
and shooting crew men instilling fear is
the name of the game as a pirates and it
was working well for them they were
making a lot of money with piracy
we need from the people and our
government all to try
to make us
help and safe from here we are we all
have families in the gulf of guinea next
to nigeria the cost of piracy in stolen
goods security and insurance is around 2
billion
pirates in the gulf of guinea became so
powerful that they literally threaten
the entire oil industry
pirates are driving billion dollar oil
giants out of their countries because
they simply don't want to deal with it
we are going to break down the
production process in the brs minimum
and we are going to achieve it very soon
we are enlightened enough to know what
we want and we are fighting for it
it's actually pretty impressive when you
think about it considering how many
times big oil has proven that they can't
be taken down piracy in somalia nigeria
and other parts of the world like the
caribbean falcon lake in mexico and
indonesia have all turned into a very
profitable business
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the early 21st century pirates were a
big problem for the entire world but it
reached its peak around 2012 and then
slowly diminished when the world got
sick of pirates and finally took some
action but it doesn't mean that modern
day pirates have completely disappeared
things have calmed down a lot but piracy
has been on the rise again in 2020
especially after the stress that the
pandemic has put everyone under
how many people they are one two three
in 2020 a chemical tanker was bordered
by pirates in the gulf of guinea the
crew was forced to stay in their ship's
safety room for 24 hours while the
pirates tried everything to get to them
eventually they gave up but other ships
haven't been so lucky in january 2021
paris and the gulf of guinea attacked a
turkish container ship the pirates
kidnapped 15 crew members and one sailor
was killed during the attack it took
weeks before the 15 men were finally
freed and between january and october of
2020 there were a staggering 132 pirate
attacks compared to barely 20 pirate
attacks the year before it just goes to
show that wherever there's economic
weakness poverty joblessness political
violence large populations and proximity
to major trade lines you're gonna have
pirates the role of government is to
have a monopoly on violence somalia's
government gave up that monopoly on
violence in their oceans nigeria's
government couldn't stand up against big
oil so in both cases pirates came in
took actions into their own hands and
filled that need for violence
there are many better ways to make money
other than being a pirates but you need
to learn the right skills that is where
brilliant comes in brilliant is a great
tool that provides you with fun
interactive courses in science
technology and math skills that can make
you a lot of money for example the
average computer scientist makes a
hundred and six thousand dollars a year
and brilliant has a learning path that
gives you a solid foundation for that
subject quantum computing engineers make
a hundred and thirty five thousand
dollars a year on average and brilliant
has an exciting course for that too
there's one on data science another one
on probability statistics and finance
and much more what makes brilliant
different is that it helps over 11
million people truly understand
important stem concepts instead of just
memorizing it instead of boring lecture
videos you get hands-on courses with
interactive problem solving you never
have to worry about feeling intimidated
by stem because brilliance courses are
presented in bite-sized pieces you learn
at your own pace and never feel
pressured and if you're having trouble
with a topic brilliant has super
detailed explanations that breaks
everything down piece by piece for you
on the spot so start learning how to
think like a mathematician mechanical
engineer or data analyst we're brilliant
today
to get started for free visit
brilliant.org trend or click the link
below the first 200 of my subscribers
will get percent off brilliant annual
premium subscription that's
brilliant.org that's jake tran for 20
off if you're one of the first 200
people thanks to brilliant for
sponsoring this video
i remember watching the somalia pirates
episode of south park as a kid and that
was by far one of my favorite south park
episodes so i'm really happy to be able
to make this video and explain stuff
that isn't really talked about anywhere
else but yeah thanks for watching and if
you're new here my name is jake and we
make documentaries on money power and
crime just like this one every single
week multiple times a week for free so
you might as well click that subscribe
button because you have nothing to lose
and everything they gain and you can
always dislike and unsubscribe whenever
you want and if you want longer
documentaries are even more
controversial every single month you can
click that join button below because
those ones are even more controversial
so i can't post them publicly and
there's a refund policy too if you don't
like it for whatever reason email me and
i will refund you the money you can
follow me on instagram at jtrend.io
that's going to wrap it up thanks for
watching stay dangerous out there and i
will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you